for Black History Month we are
celebrating trailblazers who became
leaders in their field and helped change
the course of history big time this
morning we hear from two civil rights
attorneys one is fred gray he was a
lawyer for Rosa Parks during the
Montgomery bus boycott back in 1955 and
dr. Martin Luther King jr. and Alabama
native great is now 89 years old
Benjamin Crump is a renowned attorney
known for representing the families of
the slain teenagers Trayvon Martin in
Florida and Michael Brown in Missouri
Crump who is 50 years old practices law
in five states and in Washington DC Gray
has mentored Crump for more than 20
years we brought them together at the
Tuskegee History Center in Alabama to
talk about their life's work and paving
the way for countless others in the
modern civil rights movement I didn't
have the privilege of going to enter
integrated anything yes sir
and my whole idea was to destroy
segregation I started going to the NAACP
meetings and I met Rosa Parks we would
sit and share our lunches and talk about
the problems so on December 1st it was
like any other day that we had talked we
had our lunch came back late in the
evening and I had phone calls from a
whole lot of people and I found out that
miss parks had been arrested
I went over she told me she wanted me to
represent her and I told I would but I
also told us about miss parks you know
we've been dealing with this problem on
the buses for a long time now
[Music]
but you know there has been talk in the
community about people staring off of
the buses as a protest and if we're
gonna do that now is the time to make a
long story short went crosstown to join
robbing sons house and we said in her
living room on the evening of December
1st in the morning of December 2nd and
made the plans for the Montgomery bus
boycott but then we said that we need to
have the preachers involved in it amen a
majority of the Negro citizens of
Montgomery Alabama have refrain from
riding city buses since December 5th
that's how dr. King was introduced and
being officially dr. King was made and
appointed the spokesman for the group
and the rest of it is history outrage
over the fatal shooting of 17 year-old
Trayvon Martin protesters are demanding
the arrest of that neighborhood watch
captain I think a lot went into the
background of people knowing about
Trayvon Martin and this kid who was
walking home minding his business with
this neighborhood watch volunteer with a
9-millimeter gun profile pursued and
shot him in the heart two days later his
father called
I cannot articulate
the sound that was coming from his voice
this sound of heart brokenness he said
my son Trayvon Martin was walking home
from the 7-eleven and the neighborhood
watch volunteer shot and killed him
there are two battles it's the bout in
the court of law and about in the court
of public opinion no justice and I
understood that the only way we were
gonna win this battle in the court of
public opinion there's gonna be what the
young people in the young energy and
those young people who will become black
lives matter it was the young people on
social media who got trade by Martin to
mainstream media and it was a lesson now
that has been duplicated dozens and
dozens of times since then
frequently people will say well Fred
gray they say you did so much in the
civil rights movement I never did see
you out there marching I said that's
correct
our only Moyes for ceremonial reasons my
role was not to march my role was to get
the law and have the law protect the
individuals so they could March the
civil rights march consisted of people
doing a lot of things so I made speeches
some marched some did legal work but it
took all of it but it was because we
worked together and was able to do it
but the struggle continues our ways
marvel at what dr. King said when he
said we all have a role to play in the
struggle
oh I got goose bumps what a piece I mean
every time I see Trayvon Martin's face
looking at the camera that way it makes
my heart skip a beat because I I took
that story so hard at the time and I got
to meet his parents and it just didn't
make any sense I mean oh the role that
Benjamin Crump played and now Fred great
talking about Rosa Parks so glad with
every people like Fred Fred gray still
around to tell us those stories that's
the story it's amazing how much things
change but also how much they stay the
same you saw the pictures in the Rosa
Parks era people on the phone calling
each other organizing and with Trayvon
Martin you saw the phones like this
sharing the video is people organizing
yeah and it's amazing how one phone call
like that from Rosa Parks it's a gray
can change so much that's still it's
still that's still the same today one
phone call can make a difference yo
special shout-out mommy hug sadena fry
who did that they call her D fry around
here because it you don't know this at
home but it's very hard to do a piece
with no track where you just have people
telling the story nice job a lot of
working out beautifully done